dude you'll see like reaction channels
and they're like they're like
i'm kind of a big deal now i'm kind of a
[ __ ] that's like bro bro like chill
like chill i see i see the [ __ ] you're
posting on twitter i'm just like bro
just just
just stop man the audacity of this man
is just insane it's just like you like
there are like
a few channels who could be complete
[ __ ] and i'd be like i'm still gonna
watch dude you're [ __ ]
god-tier content yeah yeah yeah you
deserve a good dick sucking yeah but
most of us are shitty youtubers
who don't make anything so don't get an
ego we don't do anything impressive yeah
you're not you know like and i think i
think having that attitude towards it
like
give us i i age one of my videos of my
baby and i care so much about it but i
never
ever think i'm i'm like anything special
yeah i think i think that goes a long
way in making you a down-to-earth person
and personality
being humble goes a very very long way
right and and that's what it is like as
god said before right like youtube is
just a friendship simulator yeah
if you want to get those friendships
being humble is probably the best
personality trait you can have on
youtube oh dude dude i've
made some of the best friends of my life
from each other aren't you guys right
yeah exactly
here we here we are now the boys the
boys wouldn't have come together if one
of us was a dick
everyone everyone i've met and yeah
obviously including you guys it's just
like you
mean you just have this like you can
totally tell that they just don't see
themselves as anything
special no i mean i feel like very lucky
to be in the
place that i am not saying i wake up and
i'm like man i'm [ __ ]
lucky to be here man dude i'm gonna
smash a combini sandwich and
get back to work this is amazing like
i'm into [ __ ] japan
yeah i know meanwhile like people with
like 100k subs or just like the massive
ego is like where's my caviar
in the morning i've seen i've seen some
abhorrent behavior from people who
just think they're hot [ __ ] yeah i'm
like and then this is this isn't just
limited to youtube
but like like instagram oh instagram is
saying
my god like oh god just chill it just
don't
don't be an [ __ ] that's that's that's
the thing you want to be a successful
youtuber
don't be a dear but also i think
thinking about the future as well
think and just planning ahead i think is
also important because
for like when you hear about youtuber's
success stories everyone always just
everyone always just sees oh man they're
growing so [ __ ] quickly right
i want that i want to go i want to grow
quickly but what
they don't see a lot of the times is how
[ __ ] long a lot of these youtubers
worked
before that yeah right because you
always you always see that one youtuber
who rises up quickly like
mr beast for example mr beast was like i
think it was last year or two years ago
he was like
the hardest [ __ ] on youtube in terms of
still kind of issues i mean he still is
he's still like once approaching like 50
million he's like one of the biggest
creators on this platform but
what a lot of people don't talk about is
just how many times he had
failed and how many different kinds of
content that he did and he's like
if you want to be a youtuber you're
going to put in the grind and it is
going to be
a grind and not a lot of youtubers talk
about the grinds they put into before
they were like successful
because everyone always sees that
massive [ __ ] year that they had
right but like i remember being a small
youtuber and working like
i've been on youtube for 13 years and
most of that 13 years was being a
[ __ ] nobody
you know what i mean i have a question
how many years did you work on your
youtube channel
before you saw a penny
like seven eight years and then rice you
know okay cause do you forget those
comments where people like
dude youtubers make too much money yeah
and then i always just tell them
dude work for seven years for nothing
and then see if you like
if you want tell me you want to work for
seven years at the chance of being
successful and getting some money
and it's also a system that allows some
amazing things
the reason why some people make you know
like i'm i'm never gonna make nearly as
much money as someone like logan or jake
paul
makes yeah but that system is also in
place so that that one animator who
makes one video a month can just make
enough to get by
yeah because if logan paul and jake paul
didn't make that much then the
animator down there couldn't make that
much you know what i mean yeah and it's
it's yeah some of these youtubers have
way too much [ __ ] money oh yeah but
yeah it's a system that you know you
only see the success and you never like
you said you never see the hard work
you never see the 40 hours a week i was
putting in while trying to get a degree
yeah when we say rise and grind we mean
that half as a joke like we
genuinely mean that i mean we talked
about how we try to have a
less hands-on approach now like you know
some some of us to varying degrees
like like any business you you you grow
and you
delegate jobs like i don't think there
is literally
a youtuber i know that hasn't gone
through a period
where they just wanted to where all they
did was do youtube
from moment to night from like waking up
tonight like there was a year
i'm sure for all three of us where we
just this was all we did oh yeah and we
put in that [ __ ] grind and
the hard part was learning once we were
successful how to get out of this grind
because it's like unsustainable
but you got to be prepared to put the
work in because it is going to be
really really hard [ __ ] work because
you got to compete with everyone and
every youtuber i know
has gone through a period where they've
just wanted to [ __ ] kill themselves
for how much work they've done
but that's that's just the landscape
right because that's how much people
want to succeed and if you're not
prepared to do that for like
a year at least because some people do
it minimum like a minimum
you got to do this for a year doesn't
matter what kind of life situation
you're in
whether you're in like [ __ ] uni like
you're working you've got a job
youtube doesn't care youtube doesn't
wait for that [ __ ] it's unfortunate
because
you know obviously likely the more older
you get the more responsibilities you
have which means with less time for
youtube and it just
it sucks because life isn't [ __ ] fair
and you know we're really lucky that we
all started at like a perfect time which
is in university where we could afford
to
throw everything else out the window you
know and i feel bad you know because
sometimes you get emails from people who
are like
you know working fathers yeah and you're
like
hey i really need to do x and x and i'm
like [ __ ] dude like i mean
it's kind of hard because you really
have to put in way more time than you
could ever put in in your situation
and it sucks because it's not fair it's
it's not because
like for me when when people ask me what
is what do i have to do to like make
youtube my job
the first thing i ask them no matter how
many like sub counts they are
one thing about making this a job i'm
like are you prepared to take a year out
of your life
to make it work to make it work at least
a year out of your life if you're
prepared to take a year out of your life
to make this work then it's
something i think it's feasible with the
right work ethic but it's not just about
work it's not just about
because with youtube you not only have
to work hard you have to work smart
as well to stand out and that's not even
a guarantee right like that that one
year is like
you have a chance yeah but like okay
here's if if we're throwing pure numbers
into this
into the algorithm i feel like if you
have over 100 000 subscribers
you can make this into a job yeah you
probably could you're maybe not right at
that point but you can easily get
like like with the good amount of views
yeah i reckon
with a healthy amount of views like if
if you had if you've just like obviously
just reached 100 000
and you you have to quit your job don't
go yeah yeah yeah i'm not i'm not saying
you can quit your job but you do
have a chance to make this a job if you
play your cards right
but like i said are you prepared to take
a year out of your life maybe you know
what i mean yeah like it's
it's that's that's kind of like the
crossroads i've seen a lot of people
and there's also you know you might see
a channel and they might have gotten
like a big burst of numbers but there's
maybe something going on in the channel
that's quite unhealthy
right like you can see like if they have
if their channel is like low views low
views low views low views and one
big view and that's all that's
consistently what they're getting it's
normally a bad sign
yeah yeah like we we can just see a
channel and we can
no no if it's gonna be like successful
yeah because most of the time if you
reach a hundred thousand you have
some kind of a thousand you're doing
you've got a foundation and
it's this is like unless you've just had
one bang of video and then you've just
reached hundred thousand but like
most like i'm throwing this out but like
most of the cases
i know where someone reaches a hundred
thousand i knew that they could turn it
into a job it was something
that you won't be living well when you
when you started off
well none of us did none of us were i
was worrying about being kicked out of
my house
yeah so that was fun but but if you
understand enough about how to monetize
your work and the internet like [ __ ]
artists
please please learn how to monetize your
work there's so many talented people out
there
where they're not making a single penny
because they don't know how to market
their skill sets
like if if you just do a bit of research
about how to market yourself and how to
monetize
your platform you can make this a job um
i truly do think anyone can be a
youtuber like it's not i do as well
i think it if it just takes different
amounts of time for different people
yeah but i think anyone can do it some
people are just clicks for some people
you really
i already know so at the end of the day
you know and even if you're
working father with 10 kids i'm sure
there is a chance or some path that you
could make it work right if that's
it's hard man i mean it there's there's
no there's no foolproof way to make it
happen
we're not saying it's easy there's no
foolproof way but there is
i guess ways that you can increase your
chances i hope there's a lot
of there's a lot of ways